Violent winds and heavy rains caused flooding and landslides overnight in Comoros...
...as Tropical Cyclone Kenneth lashed the East African island nation.
More than 3,500 African migrants have been detained by security forces in Yemen this week,...
...as they flee drought and unemployment in the Horn of Africa.
In Britain, climate change activists disrupted activity in London's financial district...
...as part of an ongoing campaign to raise awareness of the issue.
In the US, the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention...
...said 695 cases of measles have been reported nationwide,...
...the highest number on record since the ailment was declared eliminated in 2000.
Finally from Peru, authorities seized more than two tons of drugs found on a Liberian-flagged ship.